الينا مراسلنا في مسائل عربيه ليت بازاري
ومعه الشاف العالمي اكرم بن علال اهلا بك
ليث واهلا بالشاف الجزائري العالمي اكرم
[موسيقى]
بالقدير سعاد ماسي
سهام الجزائريه اليوم سهرتنا جزائريه
نادين انا واياك بس الفلسطينيه كله
الجزائريين
احنا بنقول احكيه راوي احكي حكايات مع
سعاد بعد شوي ولكن قبل منتعرف اكثر كيف
قدر يغير الشيف اكرم
او اسلوب عمل الشوربه الجزائريه المشهوره
انت اليوم بتعملها او اعاده النظر في
تحضير هذه الشوربه شو بتعمل غادي ندير
الشوربه
مختلفه
[موسيقى]
بدون الشعيريه بدل الشعيريه
بحاول دائما يشيل الاشياء بدون المس
بالعادات التقليديه او التراث الجزائري
ولكن باضافه اشياء غريبه مثل ما بنشوف
بحضر
تفضل
ببدلها للمشاهدين
[موسيقى]
الشعيريه المعروفه بالشوربه الجزائريه هو
بحط
بقلب بقلب بقلب الطبق الشوربه اللي بحضره
طبعا طبعا ما بنقدر
ننسى سعاد ماسي سعاد ماسي شو يعني شو تعني
لك الشوربه الجزائريه خصوصا انك انت كبرتي
بالجزائر
تفضلي معي
شكرا مساء الخير مساء النور على كل الناس
المشاهدين
مش حبيت نقول
الشوربه الجزائريه
تعتبر يعني هي اللي تجمعنا على في الطاوله
رمضانيه خاصه
فيها اجواء عائليه جميله جدا الكثير من
الذكريات
الفرحه الاهل هي اللي تلمنا على طاوله
الاكل نعم وهلا انت رمضان اكيد مثل كل
العرب والمسلمين يعني لهم الكثير هل
تعودنا احنا دائما في فنانين بحضروا اغاني
لرمضان هل سعاد ميسي من هذا النمط من
المغنيين
صح
انا من قبل ما نحضر نفسي للطبخ اولا لازم
ننظف المطبخ يكون
عندي اغاني خاصه لرمضان يعني ابتدي بتنظيف
كل البيت
وبعدين بحضر خصوصا موسيقى شعبيه الشعبي
الجزائري مثل قروابي او الاندلسي في وهران
بيسمعوا كثير الموسيقى الاندلسيه مش عارفه
لانه اقرب من وهران وانت من الجزائر
العاصمه
نسمع كثير موسيقى الاندلسيه
نرجع لاقرب سعاد نشوف شو حط يا صبايا اذا
شايفين اكرم بحط
هذا بتوقع دجاج
بنشوف كيف اكرم قاعد بحضر الغافيولي الحطي
بقلبه الدجاج مشان يحضر لنا طبق شهي على
كل حال احنا رح نرجع لكم باستوديو بدبي
وبعد شوي راح نكمل راح نحكي اشياء كثيره
منها
البوم سعاد ماسك جديد اللي نزل رحت تغني
لنا اكيد لاحظوا انه فينيل هذا صار نادر
ورجع على الموضه هذه الاسطوانات الكبيره
اللي كانت تسوق وراح نحكي طبعا عن احكيها
راوي ورح ناخذ راح نكون على مائده جزائريه
بامتياز لكم يا صبايا
ليث وبانتظار نسمع احكي يا راوي نعم
سامعكم اهلا
ومسائل عربيه وهينا بانتظار يعني انا انا
وسعاد جاهزين قاعدين على الطاوله طبعا
المايك ما يمكن عند صبحي اذا بنقدر نحكي
مع سعاد ونسالها عن الطاوله الرمضانيه مثل
ما شايفين اللبن
والعصير وطبعا
التمر التمر احنا طبعا التمر الجزائري
وناطرين الشيف اقرب اذا حدا بقدر يقول
للشيف اكرم احنا جوعنا وقرب الافطار كيف
كنت تقضي وقتك سعاد
قبل ساعه او ساعه الا ساعه وربع يمكن على
الافطار كيف كنت تقضي بالجزائر
[موسيقى]
الاجواء الاجواء مختلفه الاجواء مختلفه
بفضل يعني لما اكون كنا في الجزائر لان مع
العائله مع الوالده
الوالده خواتاتي
نفطر نسمع الموسيقى كيما قلت كاين دايما
شربه التمر اللي جاي من الجزائر
وعصير الحليب
انا طلبتها منك قبل شوي اسمحوا لنا يا
صبايا نادين بعرف انت بدك تسالي سعاد وبدك
تسالي الشيف اكرم اسئله كثيره بس خلينا بس
تسمع لو مقطوعه صغيره من يرى وتفضلي
[موسيقى]
احكي حكايه
ماذا بيك تكون روايه احكيلي على ناس زمان
احكيلي على الف ليله وليله على لون جابت
الخولى
على ولد السلطان حاجيتك
ما جيتك
ودينا بعيد مدى الدنيا
حاجيتك
ما جيتك
[موسيقى]
كل واحد منا في قلبه حكايه
واحد في قلبه حكايه
واحنا بقلبنا حكايه كبيره وعنا سؤال معنا
دين بتوقع تفضلي يا دين
والله كل الاسئله ما بتحكي اليوم
[ضحك]
الاكل اللي خلاني انزل كل الاسئله
شفت كيف شفت خطيبتي كبيره ههه
حسدونا في ناس من المشاهدين اكيد حسدونا
ههه
تصبح على خير ليث
لا
طيب على كل حال احنا رح نترككم واكيد يعني
ما إذا جزائريه بامتياز
بعد بكره هالمره من هو ما خلص الوقت بس
انا بدي شغله واحده منك اليوم
ما سمعت اخر السؤال سهام ههه طيب
بدي سعاد ماسي تذوق شوربه العصريه اللي
عملها الشيف اكرم
ما اذن او لسه ما اذن قالولي تمام انت اول
سؤال
ما اذن عنا للاسف بدنا نقعد كمان تقريبا
اقل من ساعه بكونوا الاذان وافطار رمضان
اسال سؤال انا لاحظت
اكل ان شاء الله في مكانك وتقاسم معك يعني
رائحه طيبه ذكيه جدا
شوربه
يعني اصلها جزائري يعني اصلها يعني طبخ
تقليدي لكن اكرم عطلها عطلها صوره ونكهه
عصريه فهذا شيء جميل جدا والصحن رائع انا
كنت نشوف في الصحن جميل جدا يعني فنان
باكمل
[موسيقى]
شكرا اكرم
بدك تسالك كمان مره اخر محاوله
طيب يعني احنا بنقدر نقول انه انتهى الوقت
للاسف ولكن الحديث لا يمل معكم جميعا
وان شاء الله
بانتظار اصلا موعد الافطار ونقول لكم صحه
فطوركم يعطيك الف عافيه ليث بزاري
وتحياتنا للقديره سعاد ماسي وايضا للشيف
العالمي شكرا لكم شكرا لكم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات